hey Quinta can I bury stapler no you
can't borrow my stapler do you think
this is this is my house honey welcome
to the meeting these are some graphs
that I made a PowerPoint
yes
[Music]
hey bossman
can I go before you I just had a meeting
sure all right Thank You Justine so nice
thank you so much All Right see you
later
enjoy that water who cuts someone at a
water cooler like Washington think she
can just walk up and say hey did you
forward me that email why would you ask
me if I forwarded you to email why would
you do that you know me Dimitri you know
me I'm in the street did you forward me
the email okay when I have to send
emails Alison Stacia yo this better not
say my name is Justus oh yeah hey uh-oh
I told you to keep my name out to dirty
mouth why'd you say my name you talking
about me don't hold me back
hey even know his mom didn't end up
teaching them yo I say we go teach this
a lesson
[Music]
when I just wanted to sit you down and
apologize
oh come on girl I love you there's
nothing I have something I need to say
to both of you your behavior today has
been deplorable you're fired
he's leaving
[Music]